Look, look, there's a few neon tetras
Oh,
cute
new conger eels are timid, so there's a tree that's always shaped like a sandbox,
right?
It's only a one-day cohabitation relationship, so I took a picture of it suddenly, because we
're going to break up soon No
matter how much I think about my partner, it's useless
But everyone who calls themselves this guy,
don't leave a lover, okay
? Hey,
you
, yell out in a place like this, Ginkgo pizza bar
.
I promised you something like that.  Well,
that's it, the view was
0.3 again.  I'm not going to buy
it, but I'm gradually concentrating a If it's a business interruption, I'll do it elsewhere
Seriously, it's impossible Huh, it's the worst I want this again This is bad